how does someone go from the light side
to the dark when they're of a higher
mindset and they know better well what
would be the reason there are two really
good media examples out right now
Maleficent right you've got someone who
was lovely and was loved and was loving
and then that was taken away from her
and then she went to the dark side but
she always maintained that line of love
between her and the young girl but the
reason that she went bad was because she
was denied the expression of her love
and her particular desires to be who she
wanted to be so you get a powerful
person who gets disappointed they're
going to strike out and it's not going
to be pretty for everybody else in the
TV series once upon a time the evil
witch who's trying to kill snow white we
oh my gosh about 10 or 12 episodes in we
finally find out why she's like she is
it turns out in that story that she was
a princess but she wanted to marry the
stable boy they were madly in love they
were going to run away and she told Snow
White who was a younger girl early teens
maybe she said don't tell anybody my
secret and snow I guess oh of course I
won't and then the witch's mom who was
very ambitious and wanted to marry her
off of course to a prince not to a
stable boy is talking to Snow White
about this so I want only want the best
for my daughter and you know and she
really deserves to living in a palace
like this for the rest of her life and
you know have all the things that a
queen would get and so Snow White thinks
she is doing a favor and she tells the
mom about the stable boy and the
princess who are about to run off and be
married
and the mother kills the stable boy
right there in front of the princess
breaks her heart and needless to say she
has a grudge against Snow White and when
you see it in those terms you go well
yeah I get that not that we'd all go to
those legs and to you know that extreme
but what we're seeing again is someone
who is shattered by disappointment who
is shattered by grief who is shattered
by being stopped in the natural
progression of their lives